I love battlefield and as a longtime fan
of shooters I finally had a chance to
play hover Junkers on the HTC vive the
vive unlike the oculus rift makes use of
physical rooms and as players running
around a square between sensors in the
case of hover junkers the square could
be the multiplayer lobby which was a
small bar with a robot bartender how do
you a platform at the shooting range or
your actual hover ship used in the
multiplayer combat arena selecting a gun
and holding it with the HTC vive
controller was initially very thrilling
you could flick open the cylinder and
look through it you could turn the gun
over and look at the details from all
angles
they even scribbled words between each
cylinder groove in the revolver better
than that when you fire the gun you
actually need to use sight picture and I
found myself closing one eye to line up
shots as I do on the range I would say
that one adjustment the game probably
needs though is the ability to seat the
gun higher or lower in the palm of your
hand the virtual hands in the game are
tilted a little bit too far forward than
my natural hand which meant I had to
[ __ ] my hand back further than I
normally would to get good sight
position after practicing at the range
mostly shooting and doing manual reloads
I hopped into a round of multi player I
must say the stress of reloading trying
physically to get to your ship's
controls and selecting weapons to shoot
back with fantastic similar to the
active reload mechanic in Gears of War
you have to split your attention to many
different actions while under stress
this simulates the feel of shooting a
real firearm better than any other 2d
counterpart except maybe a receiver a
game specifically designed to simulate
how a firearm or some mechanical now for
the downside of physical shooters in a
real room the cover on the hover
platform is about belly button height so
players have a few pieces of junk
initially to build around them but as
that gets blown away you have to duck
down to get below cover while fantastic
and VR in reality you're constantly
slamming your knees into the hopefully
carpeted ground this game should
probably come with tactical kneepads
also you're constantly spinning around
to engage targets and getting wrapped up
in the HTC vive physical cable this is
not only a tripping hazard but could
break the vive if you stepped on it the
wrong way and let's be honest there are
a lot of middle-aged gamers now you can
actually rent your back playing this
game overall though hover junkers is a
great
of concepts after playing it I firmly
believe the borderland style game would
be possible in VR movement controls
being handled by your left hand worked
really well and going from a hover
platform to just accepting your virtual
feet gliding across the landscape
wouldn't be that big of a jump VR is
incredibly expensive and no particular
fully featured shooter is on the horizon
but hover Drucker's at least in concept
makes me hopeful there is nothing in 2d
gaming right now quite like picking up a
gun in VR closing one eye and squeezing
off a few rounds